こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日は
さらさせていただきますこれは
正直僕の本当の思いというかもうずっと
思っててどうしようどうしようと思ってた
ことそして1つの悩みですねちょっと僕の
悩み的な部分ではあるんでまずはその悩み
的な部分ぜひ皆様にお話ししたいと思い
ます皆さんの使ってますでしょうか
ダイレクトメッセージいろんなSNS
Twitterとかインスタとか
tiktokとかもそうなんですけども
ダイレクトメッセージDMっていう機能が
あるんですけども僕唯一解放してるのが
インスタなんですよでごくまに僕DM返し
たりするんですけどもいろんな人とこう
なんか僕に言いたいこととか動画でこうし
たらいいよとか人目につくと言いづらい
こととも聞けたりするんで結構僕参考にさ
せていただいたりたまに返したりしてるん
ですけどもそんなDMでちょっと1つ1つ
ちょっと言いたいことがあるんやなあこれ
ばかりはちょっと僕もどうしようもなくて
ちょっと
晒すしかないとひょっとしたら皆さん
晒されるかもしれませんもちろん誰かは
わかんないようにしますけどもちょっと皆
さんからいただくDMちょっと見ていき
たいと思います
はいというわけで早速DMさらさせて
いただきますあの絶対個人は特定されない
ようにするので誰か脅し入れようという
わけではないですこういうDMが届くよっ
ていうのはちょっと皆さんにお伝えしたい
なっていう感じだから
怒んないで行きますよあーこういうのとか
来ますねこんばんはあこんばんは
今度お家に行ってもいいですかピンポンは
しませんダメだわだめだわ
ピンポン押さなくてもお家に来てはいけ
ないんですええやめていただいていい
でしょうすいません
ピンポンを押す押さないの問題じゃなくて
こうなんか意図的に来るのがちょっと僕は
怖いかなというかできればあの避けて
いただきたいとは思います通りかかったと
かは全然もう仕方ないと思うんですけども
まさと来るなちょっとやめた方がいいかな
とは思います逆だったら嫌でしょねんー
成人式からスーツください自分で
自分で買ってくれ
なあ高いスーツとかももちろんあるけども
お手頃なせずは間違いなくある
スーツ使えそれだけ追い込まれてるのかも
しれないごめんそうだとしたら申し訳ない
けども
誰かから書いてくれ俺じゃなくてもいいと
は思うけどありがとうでも頼りにされて
るって事だよねありがとう
購入結構あの重いのも行きますねちょっと
読ませていただきます無職ですまたこの中
での収入源なのが理由で数ヶ月前に闇金に
手を出してしまい
返済で貯金も0円ですそれだけでは
とどまらず闇金の話にまんまと載せられ
キャッシュカードを送付してしまい先に
使われて逮捕お金が入っていた行動も凍結
され罰金を払えるお金はなく
親にも見放されてしまいました人生どん底
です本当かどうかわかんないっすよ
フィクションかもしれません
全くわかんないですけど
可能性としてはありえるよね12年前で
高校を卒業してニュージーランドの大学に
入学した時には将来の夢は希望に満ち溢れ
このような人生を送ることになると
全く想像もしていませんでした
結婚を考えているパートナーもいるため
なんとしてもこの苦しい時期をバネに人生
を変えたいと思いいろいろ考えています
仕事に関しましては長年の経験から京都の
一見さんお断りの
料理旅館の副支配人の内定をいただきまし
たすごいねすごい方ですねなんとか一歩と
踏み出せると思っていますがまだまだ給料
が入るまで日替わり金銭的な面などどう
すればいいのかわからずに悩んで時間だけ
が過ぎています
罰金の支払日も迫っていますヒカルさん
無理なお願いかもしれませんが助けて
いただけないんでしょうか
使いますなこれお前使い回してるなお前と
か一応申し訳ないですけどもあのー
ヒカルさんじゃないですはじめさんです
多分なんですけどもお金持ってそうな人に
このダイレクトメッセージを送りつけてる
可能性はありますね
ヒカルさんっていう間違いは絶対しないと
思いますけどねもちろん私自身にできる
ことがあれば何でもします一度お話だけの
聞いていただけないでしょうかよろしくお
願いいたします
ヒカルさんにお願いしますお金のこういう
のは絶対僕もやらないですけども
せめてヒカルさんではなくここ始めさんに
していただけたらまたちょっと親身になれ
たのかなと思いつつもちろん貸しませんが
間違えてはいけない部分を間違いているお
願い事のメッセージでございました結構見
てるね色々見てきたんですけども経験上
夜勤に多いのがこういうお金が困ってい
ますとか借金がすごいですとか
不倫にしてなんかすごい莫大なお金が必要
だとか何かに追われて大変だとかそういう
ちょっとお金貸してくださいっていうのは
結構きますねすいませんそれに関しては
15責任なので僕からちょっと何もでき
ないなと思って全部無視してます
自分で頑張れ僕そんな知らない人にお金
貸すほどお人好しじゃないんですいません
できることがあればやってあげたいんです
けども
それに関してはごめんじゃ次ですこういう
のも来ますねはじめさん
彼女との記念日祝って欲しいですDM呼ん
でくれたら嬉しいですはいいいねこれぜひ
とも祝いたいなと思ってますこういうの
結構きますああこの子もそうですね急に
すみません
彼氏がファンで20日誕生日でサプライズ
したくお嫁施設いただけたら嬉しいです
サプライズしたいのでぜひお願いします
なるほどこの彼氏さんのためにメッセージ
が欲しいと
素晴らしいなんか僕でいいのかなと思い
つつもなんかこういうメッセージくれて
ちょっと嬉しいですありがとうございます
あこういう方もいらっしゃいますねはじめ
しゃちょーさんメッセージ読んで
いただけると嬉しいですこの中の中やっと
結婚式を上げれるようになり私と主人の
友達がはじめしゃちょー好きな方が
とっても多いですありがとうございます
そこですごく大変で東京にいるとは思うの
ですが企画としてもう使っていただいても
いいのでもしよろしければサプライズ
ゲストとして結婚式に来ていただくことが
可能でしょうかなるほど
結構これ
来年とかの話で時間があるんですけども
なかなかね結婚式に行くのはちょっと
厳しいかもしれませんね行くのは厳しいん
ですけども
メッセージ動画くらいだったらひょっとし
て送れるかもしれませんちょっと他のも見
ていきましょうかこんにちは
YouTube好きの姉が今度家族のみで
結婚式をあげますおーおめでとうござい
ます結婚式え妹の私から動画をプレゼント
したく素敵なYouTuberの方達から
メッセージ動画をプレゼントしたいと思い
ご連絡しました進路シェイプのお名前は
こうですとお忙しいのは承知ですがこの
メッセージが目に止まってもし可能であれ
ば動画をいただけないかなと他の人に
見せる動画ではないので
身内の結婚式なのでぜひお願いします
いきなりのご連絡すみませんでしたとはい
まずなんか昨日ぐらいパッと見つけた
ほんとここ最近の一部のメッセージなん
ですけどもこういう感じなのがすごい
多いなっていう感じですまあうち来たい
ですとか来んなあとお金を貸してください
とか自分で頑張れあとはとてもありがたい
ことにこう誰かの誕生日にお祝いして
ほしいとか結婚式にお祝いムービー欲しい
来てほしいわあんまりないですけども今回
珍しいタイプでまあいろいろこのあの非常
にありがたいことに初めて社長として何か
してほしいとかメッセージが欲しいとか
そういうのですね
めっちゃ多いです実はめちゃくちゃ
多くてですね
本当に送ったことある人いませんかいると
思います結構いただいてます例えば娘息子
の誕生日で何かこうお祝いの動画が欲しい
とか何か大会とか
発表会とかのほんまに元気づける
メッセージ欲しいとか彼氏彼女が拒んで
はじめしゃちょーのメッセージ欲しい結婚
式のサプライズムービーが欲しいはじめ
しゃちょーさんから動画が欲しいという
メッセージたくさんいただいてます
たくさん
無理です
[音楽]
無理なんですよ
すいませんあのーめっちゃやってあげたい
んですよなんかそんなに僕がまだ有名じゃ
ないというかそういうの23件とかだっ
たら全然やりますよ時間もあるしやります
やらせてくださいそれで
応援してくれてる人が笑顔になるんだっ
たら僕はぜひともやりたいと思ってるん
ですけども時間がないんですよ忙しい
アピールしたくないんですけども時間が
なくてでたくさん来てさ1人だけでお湯を
メッセージあげると他の人がかわいそう
じゃないですか何であの人だけなんだなん
であの子だけなんだと
炎上しますよそれもうなので僕はもうこう
いうメッセージたくさんいただいてすごい
需要があるなとは思いつつやってあげたい
気持ちもあるんですけどもこうやり出すと
なんで俺はもらえないんだあたしはもらえ
ないんだあの人はメッセージとかもらっ
てるのになんで立ってなるからなんかね
いまだに1回もそういうサプライズ動画
送ったことがなくて非常に
悩ましいですだって結婚式とか一緒に一度
でしょうその年の誕生日も一緒にその時
だけじゃんもしその一瞬が僕のこう何か
動画で素敵なものになるのであれば是非と
もやってあげたいと思うんですけれども
やってあげたいけどもできないという現状
がずっと続いておりまして
そこで朗報です皆さん
私はじめしゃちょー
皆さんのために
動画作ります
[音楽]
何なんて大丈夫初め忙しくなっちゃわない
のなるほどなるほど確かに
すいません正直忙しい中メッセージ動画
撮るの大変ですたくさん来ちゃうよ大丈夫
あー確かにそれもありますね1日100件
とか来るとそれを取ってるだけで1日
終わってしまうかもしれません大丈夫
多分大丈夫ですということで新しく始め
ます種をというこれ
SNSっていうのかなサービスキャメロで
サービスがあるのでそれ
始めようと思いますキャネをこれ使うと何
ができるかというと皆さんがはじめしゃ
ちょーからの動画が欲しいっていう方そう
いう方から僕に動画を作ってくれっていう
依頼ができますはいこれはすごいですよ皆
さんつまりこれ何ができるようになるかと
いうとそういう今まではじめさん
メッセージお願いしますというやつをこの
キャメロに送ってくれれば僕やります
例えばこういう感じですねなんか
めちゃくちゃこれよくわかんないんです
けどもひょっとしたら
めっちゃファンだった人からのメッセージ
が来たらこう感動しちゃってるんですよ
この人も
[音楽]
ひょっとしたらもそういうことができるの
かもしれませんがサプライズ動画ってこう
いう感じだから
[音楽]
ちょっと待って
喜びすぎ喜びすぎというわけでキャミを
ちょっと画面見てみようと思いますあ
マギーさんとかやられてますねあっ
ドラコマルフォイハリーポッターの
ドラコバルぽいからもこれで動画もらい
ますえじゃあ俺後でもらおうかな
キムサチさんとかすするTVもやってます
ね結構やられてる方いらっしゃいますこれ
に僕も
初めてその参戦したいと思いますいや
ありがたいよ本当にお祝い動画とかできれ
ばやって結婚式とか盛り上げたい彼氏彼女
の誕生日盛り上げたいと思ってるんです
けどできないのでそれを可能にしてくれる
キャメを金額とかはもちろんあるんです
けどもそれでもこうやってみんなが求めて
いるはじめしゃちょーからのメッセージ
動画が送れるということがこれで可能に
なるわけですこれこれ俺も好きなんですよ
世界からのサプライズ動画さんもやられて
ますねこれちょっと1万5000円で予約
できるんだこうね
[音楽]
あーなるほどねこの人達もやってるんだ
はいという感じでこれは結構確信的という
かみんなこれ逆に言うと俺に何でも言わせ
られますよ
使い方としてはねもちろんお祝い
メッセージとか頑張るメッセージとか
誰かのサプライズ動画とかももちろん撮り
ます多分それが基本になると思うんです
けどもこういう世界からのサプライズ動画
みたいになんかもうほんと俺に言いたい
こと言わせるとかでもOKなんですよ
例えばあの大好き君という男の子がいます
とで大意識くんの彼女がいて
くんの感情が
キャメロで僕にこう注文しますと始め
大好き君と別れたいので別れのメッセージ
をお願いします」って言われたら俺もう
わかりましたって言ってもう大輔君に
大好き君こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
何々さんからのメッセージというか
別れたいって言ってましたあの
〇〇さん新しい好きな男の子が5人できた
みたいでちょっと大好き
君はもう無理かなって言ってた
ドンマイまた次の声頑張ろうな
みたいな動画も送りつけれるんですよあと
はもうね全然俺誰かの悪口言う動画でも
いいと思いますあのいじめとかやめて
ください飲み会の場で盛り上がるような
なんか動画を撮ります誰かの結婚式誕生日
サプライズ名前付きでも言いますもちろん
そしてなんと企業さんの向けにもちゃんと
ありますのであの企業の方もぜひあの
チェックしてみてくださいキャメをでその
僕からもらったはじめしゃちょーの
メッセージ動画あの
SNSとかで使っても大丈夫なので個人的
にはお祝いとかサプライズとかももちろん
したいですけどもなんかしょうがないこと
も行ってみたいなとも思ってますあいうえ
おとか言わすだけでもいいんです誰かの
メッセージでもいいのでぜひあの使ってみ
てくださいまああのすいません
無料ではないんです無料にしちゃうともう
いろんな人から初めあれやれこれあれ取っ
てくれあれでやってくるので
YouTuberやめますってなっちゃう
のであのYouTuberじゃなくて
キャメロディソンになっちゃいます限られ
た時間の中でやと思いますし人数も
やっぱりある程度絞りたいのですいません
お金はかかりますで気になる金額の方なん
ですけども紹介限定ひょっとしたら最終的
に安いかもしれないです初回
スーパー大出血サービス1本
2万円で30人分動画を作らせていただき
たいと思いますはいで多分なんだけどこの
2万円1本2万円って安い方だったと思う
割と安い方の設定なのでひょっとして
はじめしゃちょーのメッセージ動画あっ
たら
金額が上がるかもしれないし需要がなかっ
たら下がるかもしれないわかんないで枠も
今回30人最初だからちょっと多めだけど
ひょっとしたら減るかもしれないし時間が
ある時は増えるかもしれない値段と人数も
かなり変動するとは思うんですけども
初回はかなり安めかなと僕は思ってます
知らんけど自分の自由がわかんないけど
メッセージくる感じもうちょっと強がある
ような感覚はあったけどもまあ最初は
ちょっと2万円という価格で
メッセージとか取らせていただきたいと
思いますはいというわけでキャメを早速
もうねあの動画の概要欄から
去年のリンクあります俺に動画の依頼でき
ますのでぜひメッセージ
結婚式とかほんとこんな俺で盛り上がるん
だったらぜひ取らせてほしいけども僕と
いう人間は1人しかいないので全員にする
ことはできないけどそれを実現できそうな
キャメロというサービス使わせていただき
ます是非誰かのサプライズ彼氏彼女家族
学校の友達へのいたずら」「学校とか会社
でのメッセージ性のある動画ぜひ
始め社長を利用してくださいこれはね結構
俺の中でずっとやりたかった1つの悩みが
解決されることになると思います皆さんの
リクエストお待ちしておりますじゃあな
[音楽]